foreign
[Applause]
I work at Google and Mountain View and
I'm going to talk about
parsimonious learning augmented
algorithms this is a line of work that
we have been doing in for the last two
or three years
uh and this is like a
slightly uh new resource measure that we
want to introduce in this space
and this is Joint work with um
Aditya who's in the audience somewhere
uh from Utah and ashoka's faculty at bu
sanjin who Ben not so mentioned uh from
Merced and his student another Aditya
and then Manish my colleague at Guru
so just stop here anytime if you have
any questions
so the topic that we'll focus on today
is online algorithms
um
so Ben already introduced the notion of
learning augmented algorithms but I want
to restrict their attention to online
algorithms
so I'm sure most of you know this topic
quite well uh it's a great way to model
decision making under uncertainty
the setup is the following so you have
inputs to the algorithm arriving one by
one
and you have an algorithm and the goal
of the algorithm is to make a decision
that's irrevocable
so you have these inputs here you have
the algorithm and the algorithm makes
some decision it can be very general
deficient but you can't undo what it
made
that's what makes this problem
challenging
and I would like to think of handling
the unknown remember it's an online
algorithm so you don't know much about
the future
so the whole notion of handling the
unknown falls into one of two rubrics I
would like to cover them
the first is uh what we are familiar
with a little bit you know assuming the
audience is primarily computer science
uh collaborative organization people
it's a field of online algorithms
so the biggest assumption the online
algorithms make is that the future
inputs are completely unknown to the
algorithm
therefore they have to assume the worst
possible case of an adversary an active
adversary trying to disrupt the
performance of the algorithm so
therefore they tend to be very
pessimistic in nature the bounds the way
they behave in practice or even in
theory are very pessimistic because they
have to assume the worst case
in fact you know most of CSS on most
case bounds theoretical Cs and therefore
it's of that format okay they are
pessimistic in nature
and that very property makes it very
hard for online algorithms to exploit
patterns in the data because
these are worst case inputs right so
they're not there may not be any
patterns and you can't assume such
patterns exist and so you can't even
really exploit them even if they exist
and online algorithms has been studied
in various settings like Ben was talking
about uh matching and so on and it's
been studying typically in caching uh
scheduling optimization and many other
settings it's a very very natural model
that people are worked with
in contrast there is another body of law
a research community that deals with the
uncertainty uh or handling the unknown
that's Mission learning
the primary premise and machine learning
at least if you want to summarize it in
a sentence is you want to be able to
exploit the data or history from the
past
how do I take what has happened in the
past and somehow succinctly summarize
that into a compact description and you
start to predict the future that's how
most machine learning operates
so there the goal is to build uh models
that are robust that don't really focus
on small portions of the data but try to
generalize or try to identify patterns
that are
broadly across many settings and use
them to predict the future that's
another body of work that's happening
there in machine learning
so the properties they tend to have is
good and average performance you know ml
models we all know they work pretty well
on in practice so they uh most practical
instances are not really adversarial or
worse case so they tend to be pretty
good on average performance
unfortunately you know they are also
less robust outliers because they learn
the average Behavior so if you supply
them with some worst case inputs or
inputs that don't really uh fit their
expectation then they can make really
egregious errors okay I mean we all know
all the worst case examples that come up
with machine learning
and the kind of things that people have
looked at in this setting is
um
uh you can deal with predictions like
which uh which page is occurring next in
a caching uh algorithm or which job is
going to be uh how long a job is going
to run and so on so that's the kind of a
setup that happens in machine learning
and what we'll try to address is how
these two things can come together and
that's the whole goal of the uh loading
augmented study okay
so before we go into that I would like
to introduce a couple of um performance
metrics again like most of you are
familiar with this but just to set the
terminology straight
one is the competitive ratio and it is a
classical
a measure that's used in online
algorithms uh the goal of this measure
is to measure the performance of the
online algorithms with respect to an
offline adversary offline algorithm that
knows the entire history of the inputs
that's the uh quantity that they are
usually interested in
and it usually tends to be like a
multiplicative quantity for most
purposes
um
and it's used in more combinatorial
algorithm sorry
on the other hand there's another
quantity called regret which is used in
online optimization mode machine
learning settings
uh where you measure the performance of
an algorithm against a class of
benchmarks you fix a class of benchmarks
we'll see an example of that later and
you measure how well your algorithm that
you design
thus against the stars of benchmarks
and the performance is usually expressed
as a difference you know you take the
difference between what your algorithm
the cost of an algorithm if you can call
it and the cost of the optimal algorithm
uh the The Benchmark and express that
difference and that's usually called the
regret okay and it's additive quantity
and it's used in machine learning
settings
so you'll touch upon both these
quantities
okay now that we have set up all the
necessary background so what does
learning what do learning augmented
algorithms try to achieve okay
so the main goal is the following can
one improve the performance of online
algorithms when there is some possibly
wrong information about the future so
you have this algorithm uh remember
online algorithm your inputs arrive in
one by one and you have this algorithm
sitting there and uh you would like to
know if there is a prediction or an
advice or a hint or some form of
indication about the future is available
to the algorithm can that be exploited
in a probably good fashion that's the
goal of this
okay so uh I view this uh problem space
of learning augmented online algorithms
consisting of three uh main cogs
it is my personal view so one is the
metrics so we talked about
um metrics I'll just go into the detail
later another is the resources and the
third is what kind of agency Supply
so regarding metrics
you can either talk about competitive
ratio
or in common combinatorial settings or
you can talk about regretting more like
Mr settings
another set of uh aspects or another set
of characteristics of this problem
spaces performance
what are you trying to improve right so
you talk about online learning augmented
algorithms what is the goal the goal
could be I want to improve the
performance now maybe I want to improve
this metrics right I want to get a
better competitive ratio or I want to
get like a lower regret
or it could be the case that I want to
improve the memory use of the algorithms
people have looked at you know in
streaming settings for example if I know
something about the future can I use
that to cut down the space required with
the algorithm so you want to focus on
memory or like what Ben was talking
about the warm start you want to improve
the running time of the algorithm or
maybe you can use the future to improve
the running time or maybe you can use
something about the history
that's the second aspect of this problem
space
and the third is what kind of thing are
you allowed to uh allowed to have so
maybe the characteristic could be the
type of hint you know this uh this is a
very broad thing because this really
depends on what kind of ml model that
you put that in place right the
different ml models will supply
different kinds of hints and that can
have different kinds of effects on what
what you can show for that
or what kind of error measure that you
want to focus on
um so remember you want to tie back the
performance of the algorithm to how good
the oracles that's another measure or
the size of the hands you know how many
um how big the hints are like are they
like just bits or are they something
bigger
and finally another important aspect is
how many times the hints get used
uh does the algorithm need hint at every
time step or can it get away with you
know a few hints here and there right
and in fact this will be the focus of a
talk now we will look at um
use of hints as an important measure in
this whole Space
okay
so there are three main uh decided data
that you want any learning augmented
algorithm to satisfy
one is a consistency what does it mean
so consistency means that
we uh we ask the question how will the
algorithms do when the hints are good
right so you want the algorithms to
achieve
the best possible performance
assuming that the hints supplied by the
machine learned Oracle are extremely
good right in fact ideally since we are
in the online setting we want a near
offline performance the hints are good
right that's a clear goal that we can
state
but of course this alone is not enough
right because remember the machine ml
Oracle can supply you with really bad
heads right like I mean just because
it's not meant to handle every possible
case and that brings the next uh decided
which is uh robustness
so we want almost a Commerce property to
hold which is
the question there is how will the
algorithm performs when the hints are
bad
ideally we want the algorithm not to
throw up a chance saying that sorry I'm
going to do really badly because he gave
me bad hits that's not a desirable uh
property instead we want the algorithm
to gracefully fall back to a near online
performance if the hints are like very
bad you know even if they are adversary
every time the ml uh Oracle really tries
to mess around with me even in that case
I want the performance to be
degrading to like our online performance
this is a remote these are not very
symmetric cases but this is like a very
strict criteria that we won't impose
and I want to State a third criteria
which is parsimony
where
we don't ask a question do these
algorithms really use the hint only when
they are needed
and not ask for them if they are not
needed so this is again like a
performance criteria that we all impose
on this algorithms you want the
algorithms to really use hints only when
they need
because we want this property to hold
retaining both consistency and robust
Ness you don't want to sacrifice either
of these two properties not just because
you asked me to be parsimonious doesn't
mean that I just ask one hint and then
be done with it we still want these two
things
but at the same time you want them to be
query efficient
and why is this a these two are like
easily motivated but why is this an
interesting property this is because
as ml models become more complicated we
would like to make the case that it's
actually can be expensive to query large
ml models
so it's not the case that hints can come
for free every time right if the hints
take a lot of computation a lot of other
resources to compute we want to take
them to take that into account when we
develop algorithms so we want this to be
a criteria that that's interesting
all right so any questions about that
said
thanks
okay uh so in this with all the setup uh
uh done so I would like to focus on two
results in this talk
um the first so one will be on each
framework one will be on the regret
setting I'm going to be on the
competitive ratio setting but the end
goal is very similar okay
so the first one I'm going to focus on
is um online linear optimization
um it's a joint work with Aditya Ashok
and Manish it appeared last year in
Europe
thanks
okay so what is the problem here uh it's
a very very nice elegant setup it was
proposed by Martin Luther which almost
like two decades ago so here's a setup
so you have
um
okay
so let's assume that we're working in
the unit work so let B so B be the unit
ball at D dimensions
and uh it's a interactive online game it
proceeds as follows
at every time step
the algorithm is asked to choose a
vector asked to play a vector WT in this
unit ball so every time step the
algorithm's goal is to generate a vector
WT
after it responds with a vector nature
gets back to it with another Vector CT
it's called the COS vector
and you compute the loss at the step as
the inner product of the vector that the
algorithm responded
and the vector of the nature provided so
it's inner product of wpmct that's a
loss at this step
and so this I call this constraint
because you want all the actions to be
in this uh unit ball
and the objective is to minimize regret
which is defined as the difference
between the cost the loss incurred by
the algorithm which is now the inner
product of CT and WT at every time step
summed overall time
minus the single Vector I could have
played in retrospect that achieves them
as possible
so it's the difference between these two
now you see this is working against a
fixed plus a benchmark right so fixing a
benchmark just to be like a fixed Vector
in the space and you ask how well uh my
algorithm does against this of expected
let's say that you measure
and the goal of this is is to minimize
develop algorithms to minimize this
regret
so it's a very clean formulation it
captures a lot of settings and uh in
fact uh like elad has a book on this
it's a it's a widely study
so again like you might know many of
this but I just want to recap uh for
this basic setup that is a well-known
algorithm called Follow the Leader FTL
where how they respond right I mean not
every step I'm asked to respond to a
vector with a vector WT without even
knowing what's going to happen right the
best way to respond is to look at what
happened in the past and try to play
against that
so the algorithm chooses the vector WP
with the least loss over the previous
rounds and that responds with that
vector
so if the lean if the loss is like
linear then it tries to compute WT that
minimizes the history loss in some sense
and tries to respond to that that's just
a natural algorithm that you would come
up with it's FDR
and it turns out actually you can
improve the performance of the algorithm
by adding a small regularization term
instead of responding with you know
arbitrary WT you can add like a term
that regularizes not to grow too big and
that turns out to be a well-known
algorithm called follow the regular rice
leader this is with a quadratic
regularizer here
and the regret of this uh ftrl turns out
to be square root 2. so the Holy Grail
in this whole study is to get a
sublinear regret and this is great
so this is all well known here okay
that's safety
so now let's get back to how this
problem look with hints right so
constrained uh online authorization with
hits and here is a setup
identical to before except that
the beginning for every time step the
algorithm receives a hint Vector HT in
the unit Bond so in the setup
history first comes first
and then the algorithm has a chance to
look at the hint and then compose its
responsibility
and the rest of the steps are same as
before and then nature provides with
cost CT and then you compute the loss in
the same way the inner product between
the cost and WT and then you compute uh
measure the regret in the same way
the only difference is before the
algorithm plays it has a chance to uh
examine the hint that's provided with
that's all other things
okay
so
this looks like a very simple setup what
has been done here okay
so first of all let's define what what
do we mean by good hit right I mean here
we need to Define
so here I mean of course now we get a
hint but I want to quantify when is a
hint code and we use the following
definition
we say a hint is good if it's uh Alpha
correlated with the cost with the cost
that's yet to appear right so h t hint
is good if the uh angle between this and
CT is at least some Alpha think of alpha
small constant Alpha times the length of
City
that's what uh that's what we mean by
and to be good and geometrically look
something like this no this is a hint
that's uh that's a no this is the cost
Factor that's unknown and this criteria
defines some kind of a hyperplane and so
all the hints all the vectors that fall
into this part are considered good and
everything else considered back
so that's a notion of what a good hit
means
it's a very reasonable notion to think
about it all I'm asking is a mild
correlation with what's going to happen
in the future
okay and the notion of query cost
we'll use this um we'll use the query
cost of alpha time CT Square
so whenever we query we say that we
incur this cost regardless of this
quality you know we don't charge we know
we don't charge the cost only for Good
Hits we just charge regardless of what
the what the what the hint is so this is
a query cost
S
no because that will reveal information
exactly yeah we don't open the query
cost but we'll measure this as part of
the algorithms performance
are the hints involved in the decision
for w star no no W Stars
can you elaborate it for me I don't
understand why this is a natural
character
oh
um in terms of the hard cases when the
seas are large to this kind of
capitalism
same question
problem for the first time I just
briefly delve into the history of this
as I said the the holy grail and this
problem is to get a sublinear uh regret
bound Sublime means you know the average
uh performance approach is like a fixed
Benchmark that's what it means
and the original paper and the
subsequent work you can obtain regrets
that are tight actually like square root
T and then you can't do anything more
than that right that's in fact the
random cost vectors case is a hard
instance for this you can't do better
than that
okay
so this problem was considered many
years ago by elad and Nimrod who showed
that
if the first coordinate of the cost is
known to the algorithm
and it if it has sufficient contribution
to the cost that means his magnitude is
at least Alpha
then you can do substantially better you
can get almost you can get a log regret
that's what they showed in 2007 so they
have some dependence on like Dimension
and so on how much they are correlated
this one but it's like a result in the
direction you get a think of this as
somebody is providing you a hint about
the first coordinate and that hint is
like sufficiently you know good okay
foreign
so uh recently fairly recently uh decal
a towel and I don't have sneakers in the
audience
um so they considered a more uh robust
version of this
more actually consistent version of this
where they showed that if every hint is
Alpha correlated with the cost
you can actually still get a logarithm
right it's not something about the first
coordinate but all I care about is that
when I get a hint it doesn't be
sufficiently correlated with the cost so
this is a consistent result
and they even have an improvement over d
so this result is consistent right
basically if the hints are very
correlated you get a log regret I mean
log regret is you know the best thing
you can do in some sense right
but it's not robust uh in fact we don't
know how to make their proof robust in
fact if even if one step of their uh of
their algorithm does not get the
well correlated hint then uh as far as
we know the proof may not go through
and of course it's not parsimonial
because we need the hint at every test
foreign
recently we worked on this problem uh
and we
made this result robust
uh using actually different techniques
uh so what we showed is that same set of
others so what we showed is that if most
hints are alpha correlated
you don't need all of them to be Alpha
correlated most Alpha correlated
then you can still get like a
logarithmet in fact we can even improve
the dependence on Dimension you can make
it completely go away
so this result is an improvement of this
because it's now has become robust no
you know I don't need to uh know which
teams are good opportunities are bad I
can even deal with bad hands sometimes
I'm sorry
oh so okay good point what does most
mean so the I've tried to drop all the
dependence on um uh the actual number of
hints that are bad but you can
quantitatively relate to find no certain
number of things are bad then that
translates correspondingly to uh
aggregate for example if uh say uh I
mean technically I will come to that
exact bound later but suppose say B of
the hints are bad you get regret
something like root B
so yeah I did a Simplicity I dropped
this Independence you need to know how
many
uh no technically no
so but it's not parsimonious because our
algorithm does require a hint at every
time step for it to work
this is a history of the problem here
um so here is the main result
this is exactly what you were asking
about if there are B bad heads then we
can show an algorithm that if there are
be bad hints then it obtains a regret of
square root B log p over Alpha that's
the main result
so let's start with this quantity again
I've simplified this the actual
expression is a little bit more messy
but this is a spirit of this very
similar
it is consistent because suppose all the
hints are good
that means uh b0 remember our notion of
goodness hint is Alpha correlated with
the cost if all the hints are good b0 so
you get back to log P regret okay
and it's robust because even if
everything is bad
B is equal to T then uh I mean this
expression gives you a root t log T but
actually you don't need the log the
complicated expression gets rid of the
law so you actually get back root T so
even if every hint is bad I suppose
Supply the algorithm with a random hint
at every time step still doesn't go back
you still get a rookie regret
and the expected cost is square root t
so you have like a sub linear cost of
querying them along
that's the main result that we have
okay so just like yeah sorry
yeah good point yeah so I've tried to
brush some things under the rug but
didn't work so algorithm needs to know
Alpha
that's one of the open problems that we
don't know how to solve so what if my
cost is like a constant in the finance
of the CT of the query like how robust
is this is it really like you dependent
on that you define
anything I think it's fairly robust but
I don't know if we have push the
boundaries
the expectation result here do you
expect this you know to be Group B plus
log T eventually that's a actual
complicated expression next
so I'll ensure a little bit later
so what is a key idea here it's very
simple so there are two ideas
what is that
we would like to use FTR as much as
possible because if careless now has
rooty regret and so on
but there are cases where FTR might fail
here is an example right here's an
unknown cost vector and the hinge
supplied is super good
but ftrl gives you like a bad you know
it's an uncorrelated uh Vector so in
this case we would like to actually use
a hint if possible
because you know we want to ignore
whatever FTR says and just use it okay
so if carer is unable to predict the
cost then uh the hint is actually better
to use okay
so in this case you would like to query
the ml Oracle use the hint and
you know in a very stylized sitting with
by querying the Oracle root T times I
can cancel off the root be regret that
if we are producers that's C high level
idea here the if FDR fails
but FTR may not fail so there are cases
where you want to use FDR so if TRL is
really well correlated with in this case
no here's unknown Vector cost and here
is output of ftrl it's really well
correlated with the cost
in which case I don't want to use a hint
no because it's a waste of uh a query in
some sense in this case we want to use
FTR
so
in fact using the hint actually the
hints are bad using the hints may
actually hurt we don't want to use that
but in this case how do we control the
regret that's a basic question and in
fact a bigger question is how do we
detect which of these two cases we are
at right we don't know because
everything is unknown here
okay so it's a mild another side where
it turns out that uh I mean the question
that all asked
if the costs are sufficiently big okay
then it turns out it's actually an easy
case for FTL so FTR in fact FTL and
therefore ftrl also achieves like a log
regret it's a done by a work of Guang at
all so if the costs are big then it's
kind of easy case for FDR
so you can modify their analysis to show
even for FDR so you want to keep this
you know result in mind somehow
okay so here is the uh I won't go into
the details of the blue but I'll give
you a high level idea yeah
uh intuition
I don't know if I can explain it in a
short video Aditya do you have any
intuition
changes right very slightly from from
iteration
uh your regret is much better
so it's enormous outside the sound right
yes
so again if you have two cases
um where the hints are really good so
they kind of remove uh Alpha minus Alpha
factor from the total regret okay in
this case we would actually query the
Oracle rooty times to remove all the
regret that's one case
and this case two is when FTR itself is
just better than hence on average and
the main uh thing that we show is that
if this is the case then it implies a
condition that I put in the last slide
so basically it means that the total sum
of all the costs is actually
sufficiently large and that's Aditya is
saying that actually means the op
doesn't move much and therefore you get
like a logarithm
these are the two cases that we need to
handle
yes exactly how do you detect them and
for that
so that's the main question right how do
you detect this on the Fly
and the main idea here is to use uh
another online gradient result step
to decide which of these two cases you
are on so it's like a box sitting on top
of these two things
so overall this is how the picture looks
so you have what we call a hint
probability Chooser basically this
module decides whether you want to query
for hint or not so or it is a
one-dimensional
Online daily Edition problem
with some small modification so it
decides and tells you with probability
PT choose a hints and then you flip a
coin and if it says false heads you
choose you ask for the hint and choose
again
and if it's uh if it falls tail then you
use a standard FDR
and then you shift the loss to of course
you know send the standard CT to ftrl
but they ship this loss of using this uh
PT back to the hints property Chooser so
basically it's a recursive construction
where this step
decide whether which case you are
that's the main idea here
again like you know some technical
details are involved but I won't
ask
somebody at the cost of perhaps more
computation
yeah
I don't know I mean I don't know how to
quantify the cost of computation here I
kind of assume that everything is like
linear or in this Vector size
um
yeah
but but the thing is nothing to keep in
mind is that that is for this to work we
do expert a lot of structure in the
problem and it's not like a simple any
OGD you know it has some structures that
I'm not going to detail but those things
enable these things to be put together
the structure and the problem that uh so
but anyway this is the high level idea
let's difference between exactly yeah
only this now basically the loss of
using the hint versus loss of using FTR
basically it's a it's a hint to this
probability Chooser that which of these
two cases we are I am in
and that updates the PT based on the
feedback it receives and then it
iterates
that's what it is it's a one-dimensional
problem so
just send the
value
okay
okay so that's a that's a entire
algorithm and so lower bounds so this is
the bound that we put uh in terms of
that pretty much everything is tight
here
um so you do get you do uh regard of
square root B where B is the number of
batons you need this Factor one over
Alpha we need the log T term and you
also need square root T you know
initially there was some hope that maybe
you can get an elastic result where I
can control the amount of queries I make
versus the regret I get but uh if you
query less than square root T times then
you can create instances where you get
square okay regret so basically there's
no it's a very sharp threshold there
so that way and in fact even more
interestingly uh any deterministic I
remember there's a randomization step
there right to pick in fact any
deterministic algorithm that gets log
regret will use like essentially linear
number of hits so as another interesting
separation here between a
deterministration deterministic
algorithms and atomization
it's I didn't cover this but this is in
contrast to some results that we have in
the paper on unconstrained version of
the problem so there it turns out that a
deterministic algorithm can get you like
a a local three half cigarette
okay so in the interest of time I
wouldn't go much into the lower bound so
the lower bound is essentially you know
the standard hard instance for the uh
online optimization setting you can set
up uh uh a bunch of cars and hints that
the expected uh loss of any algorithm is
zero it's like a mean zero case and then
you can show that if you supply with all
one hints then you can express the
entire regret in terms of number of
times it's bad actually so it's uh it's
a dependence on base type
Okay so
this is all I had to say about online
optimization so before I switch to
before I ask you to forget about
regret and then move to competitive
ratio any questions
[Music]
the computation of the hint itself is so
expensive I imagine you wouldn't receive
it like instantaneously right
okay so the I wouldn't call the second
part maybe the one last wonderful part
of my talk is online fashion
it's a joint work with sanjin uh uh
Aditya student and Manish it appeared uh
this a couple of months ago in XML it
so I don't need to motivate caching that
much but I just recap quickly so you
have the setup is
um online setting
you have a cache of size K and you have
page requests coming at every time step
and the goal is to access the pages from
the cache right
right and you incur a cost if the page
that being requested is not in the cache
so the goal here is to decide which
Pages live in this cache
and
um of course if I know the entire future
if I know the entire sequence of
requests then there is a very famous uh
well-known algorithm of bellary
that gives you the optimal solution
so the question is how well your
algorithm can compare against this
optimal solution in terms of this
multiplicative factor which is the
competitive ratio
that's a that's a object we study here
and with things the setup is exactly
same as online authorization except that
um the hint
we get before the algorithm decides is
the next arrival of this page now it's a
very strong notion if you think about it
so when you see a page I also get a
sense of when is it going to appear next
but let's work with this simple thing
and based on this hint I need to decide
which uh pages in the cache I need to
which page in the cache I need to throw
out in case I need to incorporate PT
into the cache
I'm saying everything else is the same
the notion of comparative ratio we're
doing the same except that I get a hint
about uh about the future arrival of
this page
okay
uh so caching with hints captures like
many settings in a nice way so if the
hints are completely error free right if
you don't make any mistakes the hints
are perfect then it turns out that you
don't really need to know the entire
sequence to compute the offline Optimum
you can just do it in an online fashion
as long as I know exactly when it's
going to appear next the bellary rules
applies actually
[Music]
they had they studied this problem of
caching with hints and I've got a bunch
of like very nice results trading of
both robustness and consistency okay so
they are all robots they are consistent
pretty much everything is tight I
believe
but they're not parsimonious no they
they kind of required the hint at every
time step
and that's exactly the uh personality
address so we ask can you get uh can you
get away by uh not asking for
entertainment times can I ask for a hint
only when I need it
okay
so to introduce this uh let me quickly
go over the marking algorithms for
caching I'm sure most of you know all
the things so it's just an analysis
framework that helps study the these
algorithms in a unified way so the
algorithm setup is very easy so you uh
initially it kind of proceeds in phases
and in every phase the beginning of
every phase all the pages are unmarked
whenever you fetch a page you mark it
and uh if you have to evict somebody
else and you pick one from the unmarked
pages in the cache and then you kick
them out right foreign
um
if the cash has selects Epsilon B some
parameter right if the cache has Epsilon
times K on monk pages that means there's
a lot of unmarked pages
then you do as before just return a
random unmarked page and be done with it
but if the cache has fewer than Epsilon
K unmarked pages
you query its next arrival time using
the Oracle
and then apply Melody on whatever
whatever you have
right so it's a interpolation between
Melody and hotel algorithm
so here no for Simplicity I'll assume
that the hints are correct hints are
good actually no there are no adversial
elements but you can extend it to the
initial case
so what you can show is that
um for any sequence P this algorithm
uses Epsilon times P hints because now
you only call the Oracle only when the
cache uh you know the number of unmarked
pages in a cache gets less than below
Epsilon and then it achieves like a log
one over its own comparative ratio
but it's still like linear number of
ends if you think about it right because
it's Epsilon times
uh linked on sequence
so
you can actually improve on that uh
here's another algorithm
um
it's again like specifying only the uh
evic Black Box
so it samples B pages from the cache say
with uh without replacement
and then for uh for these B samples each
of the samples get their next arrival
time or get the hint basically ask the
hint for when is this page from the
sample we're going to arrive next
and again apply Melody on this whatever
you're playing
it turns out that this one gets you a
lot more uh elastic relationship between
the number of queries and
competitiveness of the other
so you can show that you get like log K
to the base B comparative algorithm
which which makes at most B times this
quantity times of many queries so if the
opt is really well behaved the number of
cache misses is less than one over K to
the Epsilon you actually end up with
sublinear number of queries
uh the the proof idea is now is based on
uh third order work it uses the uh
eviction chains framework I wouldn't go
into the details
um
it's not very difficult but it turns out
that this is actually fairly tight as
well so the dependence on these things
are fairly tight you can come up with a
uh worst case instance the harder part
is to
um you know load model actually the
tricky one because you need to impose a
sequence of simplifying assumptions
about the algorithm Load One by itself
will not work so you need to assume this
algorithm has some property and then
slowly narrow down to like a very
special case
okay uh now that I'm on time precisely
um what's a conclusion
um
learning so we studied learning
augmented algorithms that are
parsimonious that do not require hints
or advisor every time step
uh I believe that this opens up a lot of
interesting algorithmic questions to
explore you know this field uh has been
developing at a rapid pace and so you
could study many of the algorithms
through this lens of parsimony uh of
course and I would like to get more
tactical applications I to date I don't
think this is this area has seen a lot
of practical gains yet or maybe they're
not been applied at Broad scale so that
would like to uh we would like to change
that
and I I always put in a plugin for this
is a kind of a complexity class I would
like to understand study propose
whatever you want to call it it's uh
kind of brings both the TCS and ml
communities together uh with the
superscript thank you
so maybe let's take one more two big
questions
[Music]
about the classic problem is
you get
okay
so it will be like some cake pencils
yeah
sure